hello everyone and welcome to a video
that's a bit different than my other
videos it's a kind of a learning video
but also a fun video and now a lot of a
lot of the times you guys have been
asking me to had to show something that
actually teaches you some chess and I
thought what better add and then the
famous end game where one player has a
king Bishop and rook and the other
player only has a king in the rook so
basically a a rook and Bishop versus a
rook now is it winning is it not winning
how do you play it how do you how do you
force a draw can you force a draw and
what not now I've never I've never
actually studied anything like this I
know something about it but I've never
I've never known the actual positions
that I need to know to like easy easily
make a drawer or easily force a win with
little time on the clock as I don't
really play all that much just over the
board and that the little clasp of chess
that I play I always thought if it rises
I you know I will probably have time on
the clock to figure it out but it's I
decided to study up a bit and explain it
to you guys in a simple manner as
possible as it's not it's not all that
difficult so basically the way it goes
there is no mystery anymore as the
Wikipedia article about the states the
the engines have solved this endgame and
the engines say that around 40% of the
positions that can arise are winning for
the side that has the bishop however of
those 40% like 36 percent are positions
that will never happen
you know if both players know how to
play chess well so basically around 4%
of the positions will actually be
winning and we're gonna check out one of
the more famous positions and we're
gonna check out how to defend if you're
the side defending so basically this
here is the famous Philidor position
regarding this setup where black only
has a rook and white has a rook and the
bishop now the point is the side that
wants to win needs to get the King over
to the sixth rank and if this is
achieved such as it is here yeah this is
the the Philidor position you can see
this set up and it will be a winning
position for white
now how do you how do you force a win
here well the point is black always
wants to be able to prevent checkmate
because here you can see that the king
guards these three squares and the blush
of guards these two squares so basically
these five squares are covered so at any
point if the rook delivers check and the
black rook is unable to block it's
checkmate
now of course black will not black will
not allow this so how does white win
well first let's go rook to f8 check
what happens black of course is gonna
block you're gonna play rook to f7 sorry
about that and now you you hand black
the move so you are controlling all of
the squares now and black can either
choose to move the rook or the King if
you move the King it's not all that
impressive because rook to f7 actually
came with the threat of rook to e7 so
now rotate will be checkmate and there
is nothing to do as the bishop covers
the a8 square whatever you do with the
King or you move the rook it's just well
rook to aah checkmate so what you can do
is just move the rook so you're gonna go
rook to eat you you don't want to go
rook to e1 or rook to e3 those are bad
squares for the rook since from from the
first rank and from the third rank the
squares from which you can check the
white King are actually light squares
and white has a light square bishop so
you prefer to keep the rook on the
second rank where you can check him from
behind using a dark square as your
opponent has a light square bishop so of
course white has to deal a deal with
this now now going rook 287 now will no
longer result in checkmate because now
you can go rook to c2 and now if check
you can just block with rook the CA so
that's not not really helping so after
this rook to eat you move what you want
to do is play rook to h7 and force black
to make another move and now black will
now have to move the rook once again
yeah we already said that if you move
the King it's it's no good because you
can just easily win so here black of
course has to go either rook to e3 or
rook to e1 let's say he goes rook to e1
doesn't really matter the point is you
you want to force the rook to the third
rank and after the rook reaches the
third rank you will you will be easily
winning so the way you do this is you
shift the rook to b7 now basically a
white constantly shifts
the road back and forth from the Kings
side to the Queen side now you play rook
to b7 where the rook is nicely defended
and again you give black the move while
threatening checkmate so look the c1
this is pretty much forced and now comes
the star move the move you know all of
our previous moves were just you know
hyping up for this move and now Bishop
to b3 now the rope from b7 nicely guards
the bishop the bishop nicely guards the
d1 square one of the reasons why we said
that the the player with the black
pieces that wants to avoid the first
rank and the third rank because these
words are light squares and you will not
be able to deliver checks so now you can
either move the rook or the King if you
move the King let's say you try
something like this this doesn't work
because the bishop also covers this
square so this will still be checkmate
so you can try King to c8 but now now
you get rook to be four you want to play
Bishop to e6 check this and mate however
the rook would be hanging so first you
move the rook now the thread is just
Bishop to e6 check and once the King
moves you will deliver checkmate so
after King to d8 you're gonna go rook
the f4 now again with the threat of
checkmate and after rook to e1 preparing
to block now you're gonna go bush of the
a4 guarding that and now preparing rook
to f8 check followed by captures so King
to see it now trying to again escape
this but now again rook the b4 and now
there isn't much you can do
rook to c1 by black and now Bishop to d7
check not not a lot of not a lot of fun
you're gonna go here and now rook to b8
check rook the c8 and the rook to see a
real characters will of course be
checkmate and
another thing for example after this
Bishop to b3 you don't have to go King
to see it you can also go King to eat
but yeah we already mentioned that that
doesn't help since the the bishop covers
the f7 square so here black needs to
move the rook you have to go rook to c3
now I tagged the bishop and now we get
Bishop to e6 everything with tempo now
guarding the the c8 square rook check
followed by blocks and characters would
mate is what's happening and now black
has to resort to some checking
so rook checks with the Shabak the b5
and now what we have here
is very similar to the starting position
although your if you remember we
mentioned that we needed the fourth
black to bring the rook to the third
rank and now that the rookies on the
third rank now we will easily win this
so better to d5 again threatening
checkmate
so rook the c3 preparing to block but
now it's rook to b7 sure so this is
something to remember after the rook is
forced to pin the bishop so it's similar
to the defense we're going to mention
but now after the rook finally moves
now it's rogue delivers check King to c8
and now rook to f7 f7 is the is the star
move again and again the mate is being
threatened so here you can try to escape
King to b8
but now rook the b7 with check and now
you either go here and if you go here
let's say just check picks up the rook
so that's not really going to work you
have to go to see it and now or now of
course
rook the b4 rook to e7 with this idea
doesn't doesn't work just yet because
you can still go King here and check
just is just met with rook the c8 so the
way you want to do this is rugby 7 check
King to see it and then now look the be
for the point
sorry not be 5 rook to be 4 now the
point is there are threats of rookies at
Bishop e6 check King moves and the
rookie delivers made the one that we've
already shown so you have to prevent
this the other thread is just rook a for
now which can also be used to deliver
checkmate so there are two possible
defenses for black one is to just go
rook to a3 to prevent this threat but
now in the best of b6 check distance
checkmate or after this rook the before
move you can go rook the d3 pinning the
bishop but it it is not a possibility
because of rook to a4 and now the point
is da 8 square is guarded by the bishop
and there is no defense against the rook
to e8 checkmate so basically whatever
black place it's gonna be checkmate so
what we've done from the start it's
actually it seems like a lot of lines
but it's really not it's basically just
a few moves so what we what we've done
is we forced black to move the rook to
the 3rd rank by delivering some checks
so in short just
check-check and rook f7 the point is we
have this setup that everything is
nicely guarded and we want to play this
basically rook a seven and rook to a
check it doesn't make sense since we
have a light square bishop that guards
this square so this is our plan and of
course the black will do everything to
prevent that so brookie - like we
mentioned you force black to waste
another move or Rock h7 now he's gonna
play something if he goes to the third
rank then we're already closer so he's
gonna go rook to e1 and now you shift
the rook rook the b7 and now it's again
his move rook to c1 he has to prevent
mate and now the star move you just
remember the star move Bishop to b3 as
now it guards the d1 square so here you
have rook to c3 attacking and now
finally Bishop to e6 everything
everything with tempo so you need to
guard this square rook the d3 check and
now Bishop to d5 and we reached the
exact same position only it's with the
black rook on the third-ranked so rook
c3 again preparing to defend and now
like we said after the star move comes
the check rook d7 checking c8 and the
rook to f7 now the f7 Square will be
deadly the King will try to escape a so
King here now check can be met with just
escaping but it will not help him
rook b7 check and now you have to go to
c8 and I was just rook to b4 and there
is nothing more to be done here this is
the threat and this is the threat so
there's not nothing to be done rook to
d3 will be played but now rook day 4 and
that's it we finally got this position
where you will deliver check on the 8th
squared that's guarded by the bishop so
this is the this is the philidor's
position and it's one of the it is the
the most famous position when it comes
to Bishop and rook versus a rook now
there there is another position and it's
very similar
jean-baptiste a lowly or lowly figured
it out so if we just move all of these
guys one square to the left
and we get this now it's of course the
dark square bishop really not a light
square bishop so you if this position
will still still be winning so these
squares are winning if if you can get
your king to the
Frank it will be a winning position now
it's different because it's much faster
for example now either either it's white
to move or black to move doesn't really
matter for example you're gonna go white
is threatening checkmate so black needs
to prepare rugby 1 he wants to defend
now Rock the a7 again threatening
checkmate
black will defend rook to b1 and now we
can immediately play our star move
Bishop to a3 without without all the
hassle we had in the field or position
so this one is a little bit quicker
and now after rook to b3 pretty much
everything the same now you go Bishop d6
with tempo threatening this rook the c3
check and Bishop here and we've again
achieved the exact same thing we've
forced the rook to the 3rd rank with
this setup and now we are easily winning
you're gonna go rogue b3 to guard
against this checkmate but now rook c7
check so after the star move comes to
check King to d8 and or B it doesn't
really matter because after either of
the Moose rook to f7 is coming now you
have the dark square bishop so of course
this square is covered and you want to
deliver checkmate here and there is
nothing and there is nothing to be done
point is that you're your star Bishop
covers the e3 square so this chair so
you will not be able to block with rook
to e3 and everything else just fails
miserably to look to f8 so we've covered
the the filter position now it's the one
like this now you can just you know try
it on your board it's once you try it a
few times you get the hang of it maybe
it's not clear immediately but I also
tried a few times and then it does sink
in so the lowly position which is 1
square to the to the left everything has
just shifted here however i if you move
the pieces further more to the left
it doesn't work because you don't have
enough squares on the Queen side
point is let's say alright this is the
position now you want to deliver
checkmate black will play rook c2 to be
able to block it and you will now try to
play your star move but for example you
cannot move your bishop all the way here
to get the star moving so you could try
this now
okay you guard the W 1 square so there
are no checks but just King c8 and now
the problem is let's say you bring the
bishop back again threatening some
checkmating ideas just rugby 1 rugby 1
loves this and now the problem is you
have you don't have enough you don't
have enough room all the way on the
Queen side to bring the rook at least 2
squares away from the black King the the
as far as you can go is rook to a7 and
the black just laughs in your face he
goes rogue a king here and there is no
checkmate and of course I'm like this
will always be met with rook rook
delivers check so it's important to
remember the the filter position the the
lowly position and that it doesn't work
if you shift the King one more square
here so these are the squares that the
white king wants to reach and here we
have one famous position that is used to
teach how to defend here and the defense
used for for the for the weaker side the
defend is called the Cochran defense by
John Cochran who figured it out now here
we have a similar position to the
Philidor position but it's really not so
if we could get our Bishop here and our
King here then okay then we have our
King on the sink 6 rank Bishop on d5 and
we will we will be able to win the game
so white will try to do this but the
black of course or will I have to have
to stop him so you do this by always
pinning the bishop and as long as the
bishop is pinned the king will not be
able to go to the 6th rank so don't try
to check the King over front from the
sides as this way you will just allow
the King to reach the 6th rank much
faster so here you're going to go it's a
rookie 1 you just waste a move and keep
the bishop in so the Cochran defense is
all about pinning the bishop and white
will try it the stronger the white
player of course he will you know use
his cunning skills to try and deceive
you but you will not fall for it because
you know that Cochran defense is all
about pinning the bishop so here black
white can try a lot of stuff oh I can
try let's say he tries King at 5 you can
just play King d8 or if you go King d5
you can just go King f8 doesn't really
matter if you try something like rook 2a
to check then you've already allowed
black move to the seventh rank and now
the King will prevent the white king
also from reaching the six track and if
the White King is unable to reach the
sixth rank there is no win here and of
course if you try something like roofed
age seven to go for some checks here
which is pretty much pointless black is
just gonna waste a move there is no
threat of checkmate as long as the king
is not on the sixth rank so here white
will try to trick black let's say King
d5 you're just gonna walk in a fake
let's say King beef or you're just gonna
repeat and now white will try to trick
you with let's say Bishop here and if he
can wiggle his King around here behind
the bishop then we will again have at
the Philidor setup and the white will be
will be winning however now you just go
rookie 7 once the bishop moves now
rookie 7 and now there there is no way
for white to force a win first you have
to deal with this let's say rook 8 check
now King d7 there is no there's no
reaching the 6th rank for the white king
as long as the black king is now here so
let's say king c5 you're gonna go king
c7 rook to a7 check you're gonna go back
King to d8 and yes now you you are
offering a trade here so let's say rook
day 6
but now King to c7 again and if you try
rook the c6 check let's say King d7
you're gonna go rook day 6 and again
King to b8 and now you can even allow
King to d6 because you know just push
him away rook checks from here into e6
rookie 7 check King get 5 and now you
just go back you've cut off the King
away from this 6th rank and it's it's
not a problem you you will be able to
hold this forever so just you know keep
pinning the bishop and if if white
allows it let's say he tries on trickery
then you can offer a rook trade and so
on so it does require some practice and
of course the stronger your opponent the
the more cunning he will use against you
to try and trick you in achieving some
of these positions but it's important to
know that the king should not be able to
touch these squares so either the
Philadelphus ition or the lowly position
otherwise you will you will just you
know be beaten so that's pretty much it
for this video
I've shown you the filter position I've
shown you the lowly position I've shown
you why it doesn't work if we switch it
all the way here so remember just these
four squares and we've well briefly
talked about the Cochran defense which
is all about pinning the bishop so once
you have this you know even if you have
like a minute hand on the clock if
you're playing bullet or something
you're or blitz or you've ran down on
time just remember to keep the rook here
keep wasting moves and once the the King
and Bishop move then you can go for rook
to e7 and once white figures out that
yeah he's not achieving much he's gonna
go back and then just bring the rook
back and again continue painting the
bishop sir that's the weld the
educational video that you guys
requested I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank respect which
palette and also Frank combs
Northcrest of each end the GS for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world and do
mention if you've enjoyed a video like
this as I don't know I try to explain it
as best as possible the way I understood
it so if you guys enjoyed that I can you
know try and do some more videos like
this either way let me know I think
you'll and I will see you soon